all right well it doesn't matter how we
get around to this K okay uh as I come
around here we want to reverse the we we
want to reverse engineer the M okay so
uh so I learn where the where the Joe is
okay so we know my attack is here on the
hands right there okay and we know that
that's going in his Center too okay
take those two elements and understand
that into a center has nothing to do
with how close I am to the center okay
so the my is really on the
hands don't reach don't get closer than
you are okay so this is about where
where I want to
be okay this is going to ensure that
I've I've hit the tuba
and then I hit the target okay in other
words if I come 1
in backwards towards
me I only have The Cutting portion of
the Joe right on the target there's no
margin for error at all so the cutting
portion stay there please The Cutting
portion of the Joe is The Edge okay so
the edge is on the is on the target when
you want give yourself about an inch
more okay so you're about
there okay and as we reverse engineer
back to the cut no don't you can't move
your
feet start
over Okay stay
there stay where you are there I am
again so that's how much I penetrate
keep coming around
go now don't move your feet okay so then
I had to step out and add an
angle that when I come around that's
going to be too shy cutting portion not
even on top rewind the film don't move
your
feet Boom coming down there I am perfect
okay right there is where I want so as
we come back and he's
there I am about
here so pay attention on how much Joe is
is showing past the rotating
cross if you have this much Joe showing
past the rotating cross and you're going
to overshoot that Target okay your
cutting portion is way
past so I
go H up there's that same distance do
you see how much of the rotating crosses
there
no no okay Ro there it is I'm going to
hit it perfect okay and then when I come
up I'll leave the right foot where it is
stay where you are I'm not going to hit
you I'm going to take it off angle a
little and ski so you can see that my
weapon is going to pass through the
entirety of his MK I don't want to
if I was rewind to film if I had a
little bit here I'd hit the tuba but I
miss the hand and then I only get a
little bit of
penetration likewise if I had that much
one I'm going to miss this arm and then
that's over penetration I don't need
that
much so reverse engineering the
my
boom boom there it is boom hit stay
still boom I can still displace
it so we'll just work on that my
boom
boom boom hit displ
boom I'm not asking you to spear his
throat and just make contact shift your
weight into the Y Kam and you should be
able to displace
boom hop boom say boom and your target
is that sternum
PL say boom okay I'm not pushing my
hands forward just shifting into the Yar
One More
Time
Boom okay let's try okay first let's let
me comment on the my and then I'll
comment on a common mistake
okay so I'm to be too close and you you
again an observer would know Ah that's
way too much Joe okay and so as as I
come down I'm I'm in this range I'm
going to motivate personal weapons I'm
not going to because he can he can just
step through kick yeah no dude step
through
Jesus Christ get a basic understanding
of things show me a step through what's
a step through go back what's a shuffle
so if I say step through kick which leg
are you kicking
with my left got it okay why would you
want to do that instead of a shuffle
kick because I'd be getting even closer
to you no watch the count the meat count
you're going to do a front sh front leg
kick Shuffle
Up move your back foot like you did
stop step to there kick the front leg go
back count the beat one one that's a
don't step step is your foot passes the
other foot Shuffle Up
kick
ready one two go back step through kick
one got it it makes no sense to do a
weaker kick that has a whole extra beat
to it got it here we
go I go
one okay so I move in here you again you
know I'm telling you this is a Telltale
sign I am too close and you're going to
motivate personal weapons this kick is
right there
okay you being in the right range is a
matter of how far out can I be and still
hit that Target and this is where I want
to be same step through kick not in
range go back he has to do a shuffle
front
front and then the Ki so I added a beat
to him do you get he'll never get there
okay do you
understand all right so that's a thing
on Range you you only want to hit the
target because that's as far as you can
be out you go in more than that you're
going to motivate personal weapons to
set makes no sense why are we staying
with the Joe and the Bulan okay second
point a very common mistake one two has
nothing to do with the range but people
will leave that there and enter here one
you're going to be too low and you're
actually on a
hinge so here's where his stomach is and
his body shoulders can come forward and
I'm not going to displace him because
energy is going to be absorbed in the
hinge when you are on top of the body
there's no hinge there at the sternum
plate and so you can displace him don't
pick the hinge
area
next on this point when I drop this here
and I leave it there and I enter again
I'm going to motivate the personal
weapon it's going to be your left hand
because it's weak here you just grab let
go of your bulk in and grab my Joe from
the top and you're going to lose it
okay so after you do the atos attack
this weapon or comes back up and
threatens okay and then you entering
behind the tip is what you're
doing don't leave it on the tuba boom
it's done its job check okay and then
come up bring that thing up right
away third Point let's make this more so
that you understand a projection okay so
because you're hitting with Coq you're
not just hitting with your stick so as
you come in
when I hit you I'm always in a neutral
stance I'm in a neutral stance when I
make contact always on the ski so I have
my 50/50 that's where I make contact and
the back foot is already engaging the
projection line okay so give me some
mask boom and you'll see that I'm
already grounded here he he can't push
me back and then what I do is shift my
wait for the cou
projection
don't in this drill don't hit him on the
front foot you you put your weight on
the front foot that's not the technique
ever but
likewise don't go here and then just
push with your bracelet angle there's a
projection there no different grab
okay no different he's pushing and it's
time to shift my weight boom and I
project on there it's not that I just
shift my weight and make him go
backwards okay so same thing in the
drill boom hop I hit in the neutral
50/50 and then project pop you should
get that pop on
him hit on the neutral project
okay here we go uh you know we're just
going to look at Mass okay so on target
the target because of its
mass it's friction with the ground it's
grav gravitational pull down it is
resistance okay it's not like a video
game that has no resistance to it it is
resistance okay and if my goal is to
displace it as it is in this case um I
have to overcome the resistance
okay and the way that you displace the
mass here is the way you displace the
mass always so its resistance is Yang
aspect I ground the Yang aspect it
bounces off the ground Vector foot so I
internalize it it bounces off the ground
Vector foot I internalize it again and I
send it out okay that that is why I
showed the the same exact thing so here
the Yang aspect is his spinal
displacement that he's trying to do okay
but it also includes his Mass uh as I
just described it so I ground Vector the
the Yang aspect I let it bounce off and
I project it back out so it is being
internalized one way and internalized
out the other way okay um it's just
coincidental that the it's the back foot
that's the ground vector it could have
been the front foot I could have been on
one foot it doesn't does that's not
important okay um but the structural
mechanisms are internalize the Yang
aspect coming from out in back down to
the Earth so back out then back in again
and then back along whatever line of
attack I wanted to use okay um if we
have the normal
ski it's the same thing so a lot of
people in ch's organization they do what
I call counting coup is uh you know you
I don't know Margaret what grade is it
when you learn about Native Americans in
elementary school so in fifth grade you
know you study Native Americans and a
kid and you learn this thing they did
they would count coup so for those who
don't know they had a form of ritual
combat uh very much like Point fighting
so the the like point fighting in karate
it's like the the blow that you would
score a point was
ritualistically understood to symbolize
a death blow okay so for those who don't
know Native American would have acoustic
of some kind and if they hit you on it
they could have killed you but they
didn't so you would honor the
ritualistic killing and then there
wouldn't be as much death in the tribes
okay but it always reminds me like
there's a big difference between t ing
someone with a stick and then bashing
their head in with a tomahawk it's not
quite the same so same thing happened in
sport karate uh when I started um those
blows War killing blows and a lot of
people got knocked out in point fighting
all the time but nowadays you look at it
and um you don't have that intensity the
mass isn't there to do it and you just
get these kind of like I don't know what
to call them anymore but they remind me
of counting coup so the same thing with
chiba's ski is somebody is or sometimes
I referred to it as tagging sharks I
used to be in sharks when in sharks when
I was a boy and you would watch them on
National Geographic and Jac custo hour
and they would have this pole and they
boom and they spear the dorsal fin of
the shark and they put a tag and a
homing device in it okay but it's not
harpooning with all your might you know
Moby Dick it's a different level of
penetration okay so it always reminds me
when people do in chibba organization
they have a final position it's all
jacked up mechanically because you can
see that I have this weird angle I don't
really have skeletal alignment go ahead
and push on the Joe angle and you see
that I'm not in the right place for that
um and uh you also see that my my front
grip is often times a Nel I'm doing Nel
to my own hand here and so just put push
down on the weapon push down on the
weapon and it's hard for me to hold that
thing there okay the resistance of the
target can do all of what I just did
showing with his Force line
okay um and then usually what they do is
they hit on that foot on the foot coming
in so there's really no
penetration uh if I move that over here
you can see I'm just on the the surface
like I'm tagging a shark or counting
coup um and they don't realize that some
of some of the things that you would
need is you have to overcome the initial
resistance of the target itself if we go
to ballistic punching I have to punch
the target about
here so that I can get ample penetration
on the
target so this is where striking range
is where a lot of people think this is
this is striking range don't move your
hand this is striking range but that's
counting coup okay and I never hit the
target at the end of whatever I'm doing
with my hand I always hit the target in
the middle what people think is the
middle that's where I actually make
contact and boom that drives through so
likewise when I do the normal C
I'm going to hit here
boom and once I drive the target
out here push on it push on the weapon
push hard you can see I'm just ground
vectoring again and then I shift my
weight and that's at the end where that
thing that Cha's das's finished with
would come in now it's key in the
counting coup to pay attention to that
when your foot is in the air and you're
making contact at the target at the end
of your cycle of action you
actually will not get that Target
depending on the target you you might
not ever get that foot down a lot of
people think I'm going to use Mar with
gravity here okay but if he has the
target just gently put your sword
down okay and he's at the end of a ski
turn it okay and he has his foot in the
air and he's going to land that extra
inch there a lot of people think he's
going to get his weight and it's going
to hit me he's up in the air and he's
going to get his weight there but if I'm
moving at him he's he's not going to get
that foot down okay so that has to be
the order then and the order is that I
hit from a
place where I'm actually just doing good
old boom thrusting action that I then
feel the resistance rebound it off the
back foot and that's where I get the CQ
projection and that's what we're talking
about here it's no different here even
though the hand movement is not being
utilized so when I come up I'm first
going to hit boom at that level
[Music]
on nowhere near yet displacing the
Target making contact with the target
but if he gives a force Vector back
towards me I'm just on the back foot
we're not going
anywhere then I project him out once I
feel that resistance of the
target this is where you get it do not
think you're going to do
this maybe on small people
okay all right let's uh change rules
and we know the
my on the
Joe so he goes and we're going to
reverse engineer the
mai on the Kessa okay so now he
goes cool he goes down I absorb slow
down I absor absorb same way we've been
doing so go back rewind he's trying to
hit the hands I absorb so he doesn't hit
the hands he's just I go with it okay
his weapon goes up the tip goes up too I
stay with it okay leave your tip up
don't leave it down cuz it'll go around
the outside and I don't want him to do
that I want him to come in the way he
was coming in so he's going to come
in good stay there and here's where he
would shift his
weight
okay here's now where I come
forward inside and I would do the same
thing so here I hit that horse dance and
then I shift my weight boom and
hit so you you can
see we are going to move
from go
ahead outside of personal weapon range
to the back side of the weapon of mine
and we're pretty much in head buddy
elbow range that's what you want to
understand
okay so as he comes forward to do that
I'm going to lift this
up and come straight
inside so the right foot is going to be
my grounding foot and I come straight
inside as he starts to lean that's where
I tapped at okay if I ten con let's look
at
me you can see I came off the Target
because you're moving up the circle
which is why we do a shet ton all the
time to maintain my or to create
distance okay so you only get one injury
it's inside and under his line of attack
okay not just inside cuz you do that
Tenon you're not going to have enough
penetration to do the the
strike we'll go
slow he goes I absorb see how my tip is
up he's starting to come up I'm starting
to go in boom and then
shift there's no reason to move the
other foot and there's no time to move
the other foot cuz he only took one step
so I only take one
step up it goes over my head he's
starting to enter I start to
enter
base and
project absorb lift it up he's ENT train
I'm going under don't make sure that
you're able to do
it right take a little bigger step and
now do
it
okay bigger step right and I'm going
bigger
step boom boom and
project
okay now the rotating Closs on this hand
you're as as you're coming in you're
going to drop it to parallel and that's
where it goes
under it's important that your
uko doesn't just let this go dead
they're trying to do an attack it should
have energy on it not let it start
dropping and get get ready for Emi so if
you have this
weak you're never going to project me
leave it weak leave it
weak and uh shift your weight and you're
going to see it's sliding down can you
feel it okay you see you have to have
integrity to the tip that's the
Integrity I use so it should be weight
there okay that's the energy I use to
get underneath it got it
boom
underneath okay let's go um Bing come
out and throw Tristan no Joe just put it
down just put it here we go and we're
going to do
a come on let's
go hold your
base come
on do it again hold your B same side
same side go harder let's go let's go
let's
[Music]
go God damn it stay you know why you
can't stay because I'm all you're
already falling okay so I'll hold you
push your leg where it is and this is
very
Calon
okay is the person has this torso lean
they're throwing out but they're leaning
forward okay and you were even more in
the technique there you go okay you do
this all the time that's how I need to
call you okay but if you
look this this Vector here is the
shikaku the de angle okay and so her
mass is falling on the shikaku which is
why she has to step out of it all the
time okay all right so um we'll have you
come
out and we use you again you have your
uh bing of your joke let's
go because this is what you were doing
it's very common is someone is going to
be OB here like that okay very very
calm slow slow slow slow good nice and
slow good big step cool all right so
here
again um if the camera comes behind
me you can see that he's trying to
impact the target but his impact line is
cutting through the Chicago
okay and as he shifts his weight go
ahead and do it like you were doing it
and he rotates there stay where you are
you were fine nothing you can see it's
the same thing so here when he hits the
target boom and the target offers its
resistance penetration is going to be
decreased because he has to rebound off
the target okay um and when you're
hitting something for real at this angle
which does not feel like an angle to you
okay so if I'm here at that angle and
I'll put my hand there and I extend the
that Force Vector it compromises the the
lack of the skeletal alignment even more
and generates this rotation so as you
feel the resistance of the target the
shikaku line gets even worse do you see
it's not as it's not is just it's not
just that okay it's and you're gone and
then I don't get hit or I go ah
now you're dead Okay so you have to make
sure that you're in
alignment for that back foot to be your
ground vectoring projection do you see
that okay so stay there make it
[Music]
hard okay that's what you want to hit me
with careful you don't overr rotate that
hip you see that okay we know what'll
happen if you ttin on the back foot you
actually move off the Target and so you
don't have the displacement penetration
okay but you can't over rotate that hit
either cuz you're going to miss and
you're going to be off balance okay now
why do people do that because they're
trying to go around so let's get to the
last
movement now let's start over
please come on here we
go okay yeah you could already see he's
trying to get around this thing and you
don't want to do that you that and that
is common because you're like yikes I
don't want to get hit by that thing okay
and so you're trying to go on the side
of the weapon camera over there okay so
on his first little deviation that he
did with his hips and requiring him to
move his foot he's moved to this side of
the Joe okay and people do that out of
fear because you in this technique
you're going inside the eye of the
needle okay and you're trying to go
the needle I'm going to go around the
needle okay and now the
[Music]
target for him to hit it he's got to do
that
rotation okay to get that Target and now
we're in that same problem here is the
impact line and then here is that chaku
line okay so
instead put your weapon back on it
change that foot to the back and go
underneath it he's right underneath
it and now your an angle only requires
this foot to go right inside on his
Center Line to make sure see my feet yes
that's about how far you are from his
but you're in deeper don't have your
front foot come out here okay so you go
W that's it that's the angle right there
move out of the way and there we are
right there
again okay got it so careful of that
cowardice that wants you to go around
the outside instead of like you you
should be
salivating got you Bo do you
understand not should be like whoa oh he
almost got me let me hit him that's the
wrong mindset okay all right try it
again